Twitter is undeniably collapsing at this
point in time The Defenders of Elon
musk's takeover insist everything is
fine any user of Twitter if you're
paying attention you can tell something
is not right on the platform we now have
a new report
Twitter hit by a staggering
59 drop in U.S ad sales Twitter's Us ad
Revenue has plunged dramatically in the
wake of Elon musk's takeover of the site
according to the New York Times the
newspaper reports an internal Twitter
presentation showed the company's
American ad sales in the five weeks from
April 1 into early May were at 88
million dollars a whopping 59 percent
lower than the same period a year
earlier unnamed current and former
employees say Twitter's ad sales staff
are worried that advertisers may have
throttled spending out of concern about
an increase in hate speech and porn on
the platform along with a surge in
advertisements for cannabis products and
online gambling six Ad Agency Executives
say clients continue to limit Twitter
spending out of confusion about musk's
changes to the site as well as
inconsistent support from Twitter
meanwhile Twitter's head of brand safety
and AD quality will be leaving this was
announced three days ago this is AJ
Brown Twitter head of brand safety and
AD quality has decided to leave
additionally we found that Twitter's
head of trust and safety has resigned
this is Ella Irwin told Reuters Thursday
she's out she has faced criticism for
lacks protections against harmful
content since musk acquired the platform
apparently unable to do anything about
it she has also resigned so listen
um
I I am actually I don't find this to be
a great thing you know I've been on
Twitter for a long time and spelled
spent time building a following and have
made some great contacts on Twitter and
Twitter as we know it has essentially
been destroyed the verified feed is now
useless because anybody can just pay
eight bucks to get verified I used to
you I know people like oh David that's
so elitist I would communicate with
other verified people on Twitter and the
verification serve to say this is really
that person I don't now have to wonder
is this AOC or is this the AOC parody
account that Elon Musk was signal
boosting that was a bad move
the new algorithmic for you feed I
looked at it today it was posts from
Michael Knowles Matt Walsh and Brigitte
Gabriel that's what for you was pitching
to me
um people who don't pay the eight bucks
are getting de-prioritized in the
algorithm they're admitting this this
isn't even me saying that Elon Musk said
paying gets you prioritized in the
algorithm so I'm really not posting much
and many people have written to me and
said David are you going to a different
platform I'm on Blue Sky but blue sky is
really really small I don't know whether
there's really going to be a replacement
to Twitter something really intangibly
bad is happening on Twitter and it only
is logical to believe that it is a
result of Elon musk's takeover because
all of this stuff happened since Elon
Musk took over could it be a correlative
thing and not causative I guess maybe
but it seems pretty clear what is going
on my hope is that it turns around
because I liked Twitter I I still like
Twitter as a platform
um but at this point it's just you know
every once in a while I'll put something
up there the engagements vary so so a
ton of trolls people I have to end up
muting and so on and so forth and even
though Elon Musk claimed that ad sales
were off the charts
they're not they're not and Twitter
truly is struggling there uh by one
report Twitter's value is down about
two-thirds since Elon Musk purchased it
we will follow it but so far not exactly
a heroic and inspiring Tale